olá boa tarde
isso já é votar fica essa noção do tempo
como ainda não sabe se escalará bom dia
bom dia
amo o nome manu sob forma de burlesco e
hoje é a palavra cancros heck e convites
do texas que eu agradeço do fundo do
coração é é a de tim howard
o burlesco 15 de provocação e agora cria
lançaram o desafio as pessoas que estão
aqui é teu começar a falar do da minha
apresentação
se alguém alguma vez ouviu falar de
burlesco outra palavra burlesco podem
pôr a mão no ar
bastante pessoas disse seger eu estou
aqui pra fazer uma pequena
contextualização histórica quando surgiu
porque muita gente vai ter comigo depois
das minhas atuações ou quando outro com
mais pessoas e perguntam você que eu tô
fazia depois de terem visto estre pits e
as pessoas têm uma noção um pouco
negativa do que aqui é a palavra mais
outra palavra do vocabulário do burlesco
strip tease striptease que o que eu faço
é que o que a senhora se ganhar vou
falar fazendo as minhas colegas cá em
portugal fazem é um striptease artístico
com o tizen a provocação manter o
público sempre a cuca do que eu peço
roupa eu vou tirar se uma luva se um
sapato se a assistir a basicamente o que
nós todos fazemos é o tizen e não aqui o
striptease coco é top risinhos
restritivo que muita gente conhece que
vai em 23 dos sexos
o bruxo que acaba por ser a evolução
é do que hoje conhecemos do striptease
da indústria do sexo é como é o caso do
poder é assim que o time pudesse a
o burlesco que eu vou falar
surge na minha opinião há quem diga que
vai desde os tempos de são josé quando
perdeu a cabeça de são joão batista que
ela dançou e tal mas nem troca quero que
eu sim a deus não eu não acho que sejam
brusque neste sentido a palavra burlesco
vai da comédia del'arte século 15 site
da palavra burlar é que quer dizer para
odiar satirizar e que o clima como é lá
que faziam anos estão a par do que se
fazia pequenas peças de teatro
performance é e durante o teste de
exatos declamavam a mais do texto fosse
eu sério ou não colocavam as blue chips
a maio deste texto e mandava uma piada
ou precisavam de alguma forma algum
gesto que outro ator só azia
daí a palavra o eixo de se utilizar é o
que nós no fundo fazemos com os números
5 10 15 minutos e pegamos numa ideia e
depois 30 anos trabalhamos dela tratamos
de forma é que as pessoas se divirtam
senti estranho que passa um bocado
olharem para as reformas questão que
estão a ser feitas é que temos eu estava
civil
é isto consegue ver esta luzinha
vermelha ok libertados em flagrantes
a louis vuitton sendo que esta moça
estamos a falar do século 19 mil 864 em
inglaterra esta senhora foi a primeira
grande assim atrevo me a dizer que a
primeira é implementar o que chama de
burlesco vitoriano é da época da rainha
vitória
o que eles faziam nessa altura em que
teatros ou seja espaços do espetáculo
as pessoas vão ver as chamadas para uma
vez por exemplo que ela fazia com a
trupe dela com essas moças
ela é a senhora de maio elas pagavam em
peças de shakespeare e uma mulher entre
outros autores e faziam a chamada burla
ou seja se utilizavam e um dos aspectos
mais importantes no bruxo que o guarda
roupa e então ela evitando sendo foi a
primeira mulher naquela altura é
vestir-se do homem em certos personagens
que ela tinha o chamado gecko em que nós
chamamos hoje de andré cury e josé colin
o crossdressing e que elas faziam era
muito onde o crossdressing
danças a decoração cantava
basicamente o burlesco naquela altura e
tinham ect de canção cantavam
e pequenas pequenas performances
teatrais
ok
antes de falar de sua banca entretanto é
evitar o sangue com o tipo de espetáculo
que ela tinha com as raparigas delas só
que eram os muitos planos
elas tiveram menos sucesso na inglaterra
foram para a américa tiveram cerca de 56
anos de nova york e foram um sucesso e
norma porque os americanos e que o que
eu tinha era o chamado voto viveu o voto
viu primeiras um dos maiores gênios
informáticos os mais completos tenham
teatro música circo tudo e mais alguma
coisa foi chances sabem o que é o freak
show tinham esse gênero tozzo é completo
e quando eles viram a louis vuitton com
as meninas dela se viram também fazer
uma espécie de cópia e paz do burlesco
vitoriana e é partir daí que surgiu o
que eu chamo o grotesco classe com os 33
e os americanos criaram um número novo
que é os tickets com um de nós fica nua
no ar no desenho mas fica sempre com
estafa mamilos a paz sempre tapada e os
35 m a palavra tite aliás o verbo to be
quer retirar ou seja só o fatah está a
retirar uma luva é justin vai que
aparece aqui porque com a evolução do
dobro e chico clássico na américa coisa
é o edital e detestado é nova york
voltou para londres com as meninas dela
continua e continuará a fazer utilizando
o espetáculo que tinha e os americanos
pagarão olha que o que ela fez
e muitos artistas este é o início do
século 20 em 1910 1920 começaram a fazer
esse tipo de shows
uma delas era desfile banca é distinto
baker
teve muito sucesso na europa primeiro na
europa e depois é que os americanos
viram que ela era realmente o máximo e
ela a vida dela passou a ser de entre
frança e estados unidos entre
espetáculos mas os franceses colocaram
nela porque ela simplesmente a exótica
era de frente
no caso dela se virem na internet ela
tem um número bastante famoso que é o
das bananas
ela tem só com cinto com bananas e forma
como ela dançava como cirurgia é chamou
a atenção de francês e foi convidada
para ser artista principal do cabaré
instrumento musical fame bergé
ela trabalhou durante décadas e e ela é
das minhas maiores referências porque
ela para além de ser negra né
na europa não existia é o racismo que
tinha na américa então tudo era nós e
era considerada bailarina exótica está
agora uma pequena curiosidade em
portugal na época clássica né que o que
eu chamo época áurea dobro e chico é um
dos 40 e 50
nosso país estava sob uma ditadura de
salazar quando ela vai portugal atuar
não disseram as pessoas eu só fui para
lisboa não disseram quem é que ela era
simplesmente uma dançarina exótica
porque o termo burlesco
naquela altura em portugal não era bem
visto no fundo para mim e para todas as
pessoas que trabalham na comunidade na
área ela é uma verdadeira política e vai
lançar ela pra lá em ter vindo atuar vai
fazer outro tipo de trabalho foi fazer
trabalho de espionagem iraí o fato dela
teve ainda por portugal e ter sido muito
falado
justin vai querer é sem dúvida uma das
maiores diferenças anos 20 30 e na
américa
temos a céu e lecce l net foi a senhora
que criou o número dos lexus como podem
ver eu tem um par do ex de penas de
avestruz peça de roupa em que ela
simplesmente à medida que han han dando
o espaço ela tira a roupa e depois de
tapas com os lex sed lex criou esse
número nos anos 40 entre outros mas este
foi o mais conhecido ela descer forma
ela tenha entrado em uma loja de
antiguidades a e viu este par do ex que
era é da época dos anos 20 nos anos 20
este tipo de peça era muito usual as
senhoras da alta sociedade usava estes
lex e ela viu tão grandes que começou a
pesar pela se eu fizesse algo diferente
do que é visto e se eu fosse tirando a
roupa não ficar nó e um tapão ccomgex
então ela foi honesta ps e tornou número
quase todas nós fazemos e engraçado que
ela sempre atuava ela foi muitas vezes
detida
mesmo não mostrando o corpo todo e ela
não ficava no atenção o público achava
que ela ficava nua e aprender a aprender
um monte de vezes
depois quando chegava às quadras da
polícia os policiais realmente percebiam
ao final afinal assim não não ficou roxa
pequeno mas é isto é outra curiosidade
externos 40 e 50
wichert ser era outra senhora mesma
época que o céu é que criou o número da
banheira é um típico número que nós
chamamos de burlar que eu agora falando
é difícil em atuação é fácil de ver
porque aparecemos corró amoroso do hajj
ensino regular é cena em que se tira o
rola hoje para ir para o banho ou então
maquiar 7 e ela criou este tipo no mundo
também se tornou no clássico do oeste
quase toda a gente que se conseguir ter
uma banheira deste ano
não é crime porque pronto já é difícil
mandar fazer mais uma banheira bonita
tornas ao vivo uma coisa espetacular é
difícil ruir
digamos que naquela altura de nós uma
super sar porque ela entrou na indústria
cinematográfica de bollywood
existem muitos filmes sobre com ela ela
para além de cantar também era com que é
humorista ênfase world street fica nas
vezes assim tamils e parte mais perto de
quem revela é outra figura é é é é mais
conhecida como ela é no hall do burlesco
é que nessa foto não dá pra perceber mas
se procurar na internet
ela era considerada meu irmão famoso
bruxo porque fisicamente e na cara era a
cara chapada da meo e morrow e ela esta
senhora fazia muitos espetáculos em las
vegas las vegas
é um dos pontos mais importantes do eixo
norte americano onde existe o proesp
hall of fame foi criado certa forma por
ela porque ela criou um museu só uma vez
que tiverem curiosidade preverem peças
expostas da equipe evoluirá ceilândia
esta senhora ela já não estava viva mas
a casa desta senhora é um museu onde tem
essa espécie de todas as respostas
é tempo essa história também é da mesma
época de crise hans ainda é viva é tempo
essa história neste momento em 80 e 81
anos e ainda continua a fazer
espetáculos e ela própria e já me
perguntaram mas não é altura de fumar
não é altura de ter a sua vida e áudios
não porque o time ainda pessoas que
gostam de ver os meus espetáculos e vou
morrer a fazer isto e sem dúvida ela
quando vinha aqui ela está recendo ruiva
com o corpo espetacular
penso sem cirurgia estética
instantes depois dos anos 50
fere m a partir dos anos 60 até os anos
ovo infelizmente um adormecimento
prefiro chamar enfim do burlesco e vocês
perguntam por quê
e aí que entra a pornografia não tem
nada a ver com o eixo que a pornografia
surgiu nos anos 60 e revistas também
eróticas e antigamente as pessoas para
verem dançarinas exóticas e eu as salas
de espetáculos cabarés e quando surge a
pornografia e outros tio de mostrar o
corpo das mulheres é o burlesco deixou
de ser frequentadas pelos cabarés e e as
pessoas já não é somente as minhas
também estavam a viver deixaram de
freqüentar mas ainda assim existirão
formas como a fénix quem é viva que
continuarão a trabalhar no ativo fenini
participou em vários filmes já nos anos
80 também dolly útil para mim é o melhor
exemplo existem várias aqui estão vivas
e distante
nesse de um cimento a surgir na década
de 90 do século passado e que surge é
que o que eu chamo e todas nós chamamos
maio o neo burlesco ou seja o novo risco
o violista de que o que se fazia no
grotesco dos anos 40 e 50 que é o eixo
do clássico
exsurge conca é existe isso com muita
gente mas eu só vou conseguir falar das
minhas maiores referências neste caso é
de arte martini é de nova york ela sem
dúvida não só pela forma a ciência mas
também pelo físico é é uma forma que
está co
precisamente porque não não seguia os as
regras que o que editar no mundo da moda
com as medidas exatas magrinha ou alta o
estoque o embrulho que aliás qualquer
mulher pode pode começar a fazer
entender como esse agora morena de cor
gordas e magra e de arte martin é sem
dúvida o melhor exemplo que eu consigo
falar precisamente ela é extremamente
carismática e sem dúvida o tipo que ela
tem
não interessa se realmente existem
complexas ou não
muitos gastam infelizmente é uma forma é
um exemplo se mostrar que qualquer
aparelho mulher de qualquer idade pode
começar a fazer todos nós fazemos parte
martini
acho que temos aqui assumindo isso é que
é ser luís é também outro nome é meu ver
um dos maiores nomes
eu já tive o problema o privilégio de
falar com ela e ter formação com ela ela
foi a senhora criou o vocês vêem o copo
do xuxa pai o número do copo de
champagne
ela é conhecida é por terem inventado
vários ex novos e o o olhar da roupa o
costinha um ela também foi professora é
month técnicas os lexus por exemplo
neste momento detém o recorde mundial
o recorde mundial é de maior liquidez no
mundo agora você rápida quer 32
temos a dita von teese toda a gente
pensa que conhece a dita criou o número
do copo de martini
elas as duas atuava em duo she veículo é
ter um copo de champanhe e outra de
marketing em portugal por ser muito
rápida em portugal temos o caso do
primeiro grupo português cais do sodré
cama
que o fundo um grupo só com bailarinas
de fundo foi o carlos da silva e as
senhoritas carlet a certeza traz bruxo
português está em cerca de 70 anos e foi
começou com este grupo siet escarlates o
islã é igual à do leste que é outro
grupo quem quiser ir vê las é no caso de
estreia em lisboa
temos aqui o um boy s que é o homem com
um rapaz na versão blu ética também
existem a mãe
outro grupo que também atuam na pensão
amor é um esgoto também na zona do cais
dre royal mais no sentido música eu
estou uma espécie de banda alex giba
temos neste quesito é solo mas no
sentido dessa oriental
márcio rocha informa também é outra
forma
basta agora
está complicado
peço desculpa mas é o plasma russo que a
menina que segura na estrela também atua
é só eu
depois temos o boy é quebras éo
masculina
ok faz exatamente a mesma coisa que a
roupa tenham é e tenha que o exemplo do
voz urbana quer demais conhecidos neste
momento a nível mundial
o caso português é o senhor ser linha
que viram na outra foto
eu agora quero vos mostrar muito
rapidamente um vídeo pra vocês pra quem
nunca viu o que querem aumento é rápido
cerca de três minutos que é o número do
copo com é dita que as minhas maiores
referências
o que ela está fazendo número criado por
ela neste caso é o copo de champanhe
o que ela vai fazer 10 em passar pelas
luvas começa é tirar o festivo
sempre em tom de provocação de que vem
é dita juntamente com a orquestra luís
nos anos 90 foram realmente das
primeiras a recriarem todo o movimento
dobrou de classe usar em fatos
fantásticos porque é extremamente
importante em inglês que usar fatos
positivos em muitíssimo bonitos
conference com cristais de hoje e sempre
o andré bastos o corpete
está na meus
e aqui não dá tudo muito bem mas ela
traz um disco em colocar ela não está no
mesmo local só tirou a cueca visita e
outra parte a parte e pronto entre no
copo
basicamente é este o número criado foi
criar para ela pela quebra do eixo
espero que tenham gostado e peço
desculpa qualquer coisa